and there we still had fights about firewood
a matter of course for thousands of years of course
technology develops further
but when we have woods on our doorstep,
that are shut down more and more,
which is a mistake in my eyes
when the firewood rots and rots
and the co2 and the methane into the atmosphere goes unused
then it makes more sense to use this renewable biological fuel wood
that our forest farmers have enough at their disposal
to heat our houses
ladies and gentlemen,
the neanderthals already knew that
but the berlin government does not know that you can heat houses with wood
and yes we need to save energy
i know that but then these many gender of the greens have to name as 1st
flying through the world and then posting any pictures
wos eating ice cream in california san this is all mega and cool
ladies and gentlemen in the time the free voter is at home
make his firewood and take care of his children!